[Music]
let's go to aaron in san diego
california what's up aaron how we doing
good dr john thank you for taking my
call you got it brother what's up
um so i'm just calling um because i'm
wondering
how do i navigate interacting with my
manipulative and unfaithful
ex-girlfriend who just told me she's
pregnant with my child
whoa
didn't see that one coming
so give me a second here um
that's a lot man is it your kid
we're going to get a
dna prenatal dna test good
good um today but
yeah it's scheduled okay
uh when it's
next tuesday excellent excellent
excellent okay very cool
yeah
um what do you think you think this is
you
um
i'm pretty sure um the
the dates and everything line up okay
but there is i'd say i'm about 85 sure
it's fine okay cool
um so let's get the if you're not out of
the way if you're not
after this
interaction
blocker deleter walk away you know that
right
yes sir okay
if this turns out to be your child
then everything changes
first and most importantly this does not
mean you have to re-engage into a
romantic relationship with her right you
know that
yes okay
but
you were forever linked in a
relationship with her
so when you say
so i don't want to i don't want to think
that we're going to move forward here
without that connection okay you're in a
relationship with it now because you all
made a human together
yeah when you say evil manipulative
cheating and all those things like tell
me more about that
that sounds like spurned lover talk
um
so we were
in a relationship for two years um and
the first year
was really good it was
going exactly how
a good relationship should go
i was a little actually not a little i
was
putting way too much weight on the
relationship it was kind of
my whole identity was centered around
the relationship
and
she started seeing that
i was
really relying on her
and she would
she would ignore me towards the end of
the relationship she would ignore me for
like
three days without talking to me and
then come back and act like nothing
happened like we were great
and i would kind of
have breakdowns about that and she would
know
and i think she just assumed i would
always be there for her
and she could
just
live her own life separate for me and
she had me under her thumb so she was
going to do what she wanted
but then
uh i found out that she um
was unfaithful cheated on me with a girl
and a guy
and the girl was a one-time thing but
the guy she was in a relationship with
him
for about three months while she was
with me
um
so i so
let's back out so okay um
you ever heard of heard me talk about
fundamental attribution error i know
okay
it's just it's a nerdy psychological
term
and
i'm oversimplifying it but essentially
it's the idea
that we get in somebody else's head
and decide why they're doing whatever it
is they're doing
we judge their motives we judge their
thoughts we judge what they did and why
they did it and then we react based on
our interpretation of that judgment
okay
so you just laid out
these things that your
ex-girlfriend
did to you
and why she did them so i'm just gonna
play devil's advocate and get you give
you an alternative
uh narrative okay
okay my narrative could be
way off but i'm trying to hit the
pendulum the other way for a reason okay
okay
could have been
that you were dating this young woman
things were great
and slowly over the course of a year
she was less and less and less able to
breathe
because this guy became
a weighted blanket
because this relationship me was
everything
yeah and had to know where i was had to
know what was going on i had to breathe
and sometimes i just have to walk out
the front door
and i'm just going to disappear
not i'm not even thinking about him
i'm thinking about me
i have to breathe i still love this guy
i like him i like being with him
but he's a lot
and then
i run into somebody else who makes i i
start over time not liking who i'm
becoming forget the guy i don't like who
i'm becoming i'm somebody who's short
tempered i'm somebody who's not fun
anymore because i can't breed because my
whole life is trying to make sure this
guy's okay
i'm becoming less of a romantic partner
and more of a mother
i don't like it makes me feel yuck about
me
and then i run into some other dude
who makes me feel alive makes me feel
wild and i
screw up
and i don't know how to say it because
i'm married to someone i mean i'm dating
somebody
who has told me you're my oxygen if you
take this tank off i die
and so instead of breaking up with you
like she should have with integrity she
just slowly lets you starve
she starts disappearing stops talking to
you for days just acknowledges you she's
done she just hasn't had the courage and
the integrity to break it off officially
and formally
and
you knew something was up whether she
was cheating on you or not you didn't
you may have not known that maybe not
been in your head but you knew something
was up
yeah so here's why i told you that
you're gonna have to be in relationship
with her and you can only deal with you
that's it
why she did what she did why she's doing
what she's doing all those things you
can't control any of that
and so spending energy thinking why
she's doing what she's doing and how
because of it that is just a choice for
for that you are making to be miserable
don't do that to yourself man you're
worth more than that
you might be about to be a dad
yeah okay
this is not how you plan how old are you
man
i'm 20.
all right
so
let's put this this hat on that i'm
about to be a dad hat okay
yeah
if you get the paternity test back
it will be a shock to your system
and then
we are going to shift as fast as
possible into joy and into i'm gonna be
a great father
okay
i don't want another child being born
into
a couple of people who don't want them
here
yeah it's not how you drew it up it's
not you would have planned it if you
were you know but
you made some choices and here we are
right
so i'm gonna love this kid
sideways and forwards and to the moon
and back
and i'm gonna respect his mom or her mom
i'm gonna be
i'm gonna not get in her head and try to
decide why she's doing what she's doing
and i'm not gonna do that i'm gonna show
up to the appointments even if she
brings some stupid boy with her
i'm gonna show up to the appointments
i'm gonna treat every i'm going to bring
coffee for all three of us i'm going to
be a person of integrity even when i got
to go grip my teeth and go for a walk
myself
okay
who's i'm laying out i'm laying out all
the things that you can control
yeah because you can't control anything
else and now if there's another kid if
there's a kid along in this
you're it's there it's about them
my life is about me until i get married
and then it's about us until we have
kids
yeah right
so here we are
so
what i have found in my life that when i
get out of people's heads and i just
start dealing with what the deal is man
my life is a lot better
i'm not angry i'm not bitter all the
time
you know what i mean yeah that makes
sense yeah for sure and dude brother i
don't want to make light of you you got
hurt bad didn't you
yes definitely okay what did you learn
about dating relationships this time
um
that i need to be
i need to be the best version of myself
before i get
in another relationship i need to be
able to be stable not relying on someone
else for my happiness that's awesome
hey when you get married i'm choosing to
lean up against you and they're choosing
to lean up against me
so there is some i i i kind of push back
a little bit when you're married i mean
i'm choosing to be dependent on you and
you on me like we're making that choice
yeah when i'm dating man i want to find
out who i am find out who you are and
how we're going to work together does
that make sense
yeah definitely
um
do you believe me when i tell you you're
worth laughing having fun
yes you're worth exercising you're worth
going to have a good life yeah
yeah okay
you for sure are
and
uh
ever since we broke up uh which was
about six months ago um i
have been really trying to do that
trying to
focus on myself and
better better myself
but this is i just don't want to go back
to that you know i don't want to
fall back into those old patterns so
stay out of her head
stay in yours yeah stay out of her head
stay out of her boyfriend's head sid or
whatever
and
even if you do this
this is gonna sound crazy and she might
i
again if you've ever listened to the
show you know i'm a comic i'm
obnoxiously optimistic about stuff okay
um
but what if you sat down with her and
had a conversation before the paternity
test came out
and said hey listen we dated for like
two years
and i was immature and i smothered you
and i'm so sorry
i realize now that i made it hard for
you to breathe
and
whether or not um if this ends up being
um
my son
my daughter
i want you to know
i'm gonna love that baby
and i'm gonna partner with you over the
course of that kid's life to give that
kid a great great life
yeah what if you did that
yeah i i think that's a really good idea
that's all you can control and then if
she responds with like oh yeah
that's not you can't
you can't control that right yeah you
could know all right i'm not gonna have
these little uh a little like after
school special moment anymore but
you're controlling you can control
you're not excusing the fact that she
cheated on you that's wrong dude she
shouldn't have done that not excusing
the fact to cheat on you with multiple
people not excusing any of that kind of
stuff
but you're just looking in the mirror
and saying what can i control here
i want a great boyfriend and i'm gonna
do better next time i'm learning i'm
growing
hopefully she's learning growing too and
she might even say i'm sorry i cheated
on you
maybe not maybe not
but maybe
maybe she'll weep and say
good
probably not but
but maybe right yeah
yeah all right possibility will you call
uh shoot me a note let me know
yes definitely i will all right brother
will be thinking about you guys as you
move forward
everybody listening
get out of other people's heads
i don't i don't know why they're doing
what they're doing they are and i'm
gonna respond to what they're doing
because that's all i can do
i'm gonna respond to my attitude i'm
gonna sprawl on with my actions i'm
gonna respond with my thoughts cause
that's all i can do
that's it